Drew Rosenhaus the longtime agent of
Antonio Brown appeared on ESPN and had
this to say I wouldn't be doing this
interview if I didn't believe Antonia
these allegations are false he denies
every one of them I am very confident
that his legal team has facts that will
prove this and before we came on the air
just as we're coming on there Bill
Belichick met with the media in New
England mentioned how both Antonio and
his representatives have made statements
so I'm not going to be expanding on any
of those in II stayed pretty much true
to his word there however this was the
most one would say informational e late
in exchange practice yes how are you
preparing to play on Sunday we're taking
it one day at a time preparing for one
day at a time
Chris Brockman is our legal expert on
the phone line right now yes is Sports
Illustrated legal analyst Michael McCann
back here on the Rich Eisen show how are
you Michael well written yourself now
I'm hanging in there let's get right
into it here what decision does the NFL
have to make right now do you think they
have to make a decision whether on
Sunday and that pertains to whether or
not Goodell wants to use the
commissioners exempt list in this
situation where a player can be placed
on administrative leave he still gets
paid he still had access to his
employment benefits but he's basically
separated from the team it's mission I
use this with Adrian Peterson back in
2014
different there was of course that he
had been charged with the crime here
this is a civil lawsuit and we know very
little beyond the fact that there is a
civil claim against our and his attorney
disputed so the readers in a hard
position where a player is accused of a
pretty serious offense but the manner in
which these accused doesn't provide a
lot of operating evidence or testimony
that Goodell has to rely on well in that
then the the league can go and seek out
the accuser right the question is will
the league be able to do that get an
interview and get enough information to
make a commissioners exempt decision
before Sunday do I have that right yeah
that's right
the league could reach out to the
accuser and asked her to describe in her
own words what happened the league could
then go back to brown and say you know
we have this claim it certainly is we
needed to answer these questions I think
though instead of be hard to pull that
all this week and I say that because of
course already in the middle of the week
the accuser could have concerns about
speaking with the NFL this early on in
the process she may want her attorney to
be heavily involved the attorney may
want to regulate how that kind of
interview takes place there just isn't a
lot of time between now and the Patriots
playing the Belton's on Sunday for all
that to happen so I like sensitive the
league is probably gonna have to make a
decision without that information what
about the texts as her lawyer mentioned
and also was in the legal papers that
were filed in federal court yesterday
the or direct messages is what they
looked like to me when I saw them or
emails is what she's saying
from from Antonio to her can those be
corroborated immediately and perhaps
those alone put him on the exempt list
Mike you know it's interesting question
I guess at that point Browns lawyers as
we dispute the reliability or
authenticity of these messages I don't
think the league is going to have time
to assess whether or not they're true
whether or not they've been altered in
some way whether or not some of the
surrounding context of that exchange
like you said it looks like a text or
direct message or whether it's an email
text rest whatever it probably was part
of a larger conversation the league they
want to see what that conversation was
also the league didn't punish Tyreke
Hill after he made some pretty
incendiary remarks to his former fiancee
and that didn't warrant going on the
exempt list or being suspended so
there's some precedent that will be in
an acting alone on that kind of exchange
michael mccann of Sports Illustrated
legal expert legal analyst right here on
the Rich Eisen show what what does what
to make out of the fact that it's a
civil suit Michael what what differences
can you draw here that makes this unique
yeah so not to claim the seriousness of
it because of the fact that it's not
based on a criminal complaint there's no
sworn testimony that this happened the
police have in as far as we know
investigated and reached any conclusions
a civil lawsuit in a worst case scenario
leads to the person who loses paying the
other side money it's not as grave of a
mayor as would be a criminal complaint
and I'm sure Browns lawyers lawyer will
argue that the absence of a criminal
component to this makes the claim less
reliable and it puts Goodell in a
position where he has to rely on a civil
matter that normally wouldn't trigger
that kind of you know punishment on the
other hand Maliki Oh Elliot wasn't
charged were convicted and he was
punished for six games
Goodell hasn't always used the the
criminal process as a forum to decide
whether or not to punish someone so it's
really up to him I might by you're not
always usually thick my instinct is that
he's gonna be patient with this he's
gonna not rush to judgment because we
know so little of his point well and and
I mentioned earlier in the show I mean
the only I guess similar comparison we
could see in the world of sports
recently Derrick Rose was the subject of
a civil suit for sexual assault that was
filed in August of 2015 and it took well
over a year for the trial to take place
and for him to be found not liable when
it was all said and done so this could
take well over a year to play out
Michael is that fair to say
oh yeah especially Brown countersuit
Wow claims might happen I know that's
gonna happen because that expands the
scope of pretrial discovery but this is
not something that's going to get
resolved overnight that's going to give
us all of the thoughts unless they reach
if you like work which could always have
to learn to say let's strike a deal
let's end this but assuming that doesn't
happen it this is a little while this
will take another life if I go through
the entire season but it would be
surprising if that's the case so I don't
think the dells going to be able to rely
on really a full scope of evidence in
testimony he's going to have to make a
decision based on what he knows and the
NBA with their little greater doubt of
course was found not liable the civil
case and he wasn't charged with the
crime maybe that happens here we don't
know and do you know about the lawyer
for Antonio Brown who has made the
statement on his behalf and put forth a
vigorous denial yesterday of Darren
Hytner who's known on his own website is
the go-to lawyer for trademark filings
and disputes he obviously has some
sports clientele for legal advice does
is Antoni are gonna get a criminal
lawyer for something like this I
understand it's a civil suit but how do
how to square all this Michael yeah so a
disclosure I thought Darren back when he
was in law school I think he invited me
musa lost student to go speak down in
florida and i met him there and he
clearly has gone on to a successful
career as a sports attorney you're right
the criminal law is a different field at
this point I imagine he's going to say
that this remains a civil matter that
it's not yet turned into a criminal
issue that if it does turn into a
criminal issue if the police investigate
if it starts to ask questions
I imagine that they're a criminal
defense attorney would be brought in
because it's clearly it's all separate
field so just to sum up here Michael
the the Patriots have for the lack of a
better phrase punted to the league
office which now has to decide do we put
Antonio Brown on the commissioners
exempt list and if they do that
do they have to come up with terms on on
what needs to be met for him to be
removed from that list is that how this
all works before they make a decision on
suspension they don't have to be as
specific as choice on specific times
they have to tell him they have to give
him notice that he's being put on a list
because the league has reasonable
suspicion that he may have committed a
violent act against another person the
exempt list doesn't require criminal
charge it can require it doesn't just
require the lead comes to a belief that
a player may have committed such an an
act now it's supposedly supposed to be
temporary and limited when a player is
put on that list while Willie
investigates but temporary limited
doesn't really mean anything it's not it
doesn't say for games it doesn't say a
games it doesn't say one game it's
really up to the discretion of the
league I think if the league does place
him on it they are going to try to keep
it limited to a matter of weeks and try
to conduct fact-finding but this gets
back to the fact that I don't know how
much does the league to do so quickly
because they don't control the
information in the case of the
accusations the accuser and her
attorneys control the information and
they don't have to cooperate with the
NFL either it's not as if the NFL can
compel anyone who is either the accuser
or those around her to provide any
information the league only has
contractual authority over Brown Michael
really appreciate the time it seems that
these moments where your services are
required on this show crop up a little
bit more often these days I appreciate
the time you always it's Michael McCann
at McCann sports law on Twitter from
Sports Illustrated here in the Rich
Eisen show for more of the Rich Eisen
show tune
- audience Channel 239 on DirecTV for
free on BR Live or download the Rich
Eisen show app